millions of Europeans move around Europe
for work study and volunteering every
year the euro pass scheme streamlines
this process by providing a standardized
transparent framework for professional
documents like CVS so that EU citizens
skills and competences can be understood
in any EU country the euro pass was
needed by more than 100 million people
in the past since 2005 it's used yes but
it was too complicated that's why we
tried to simplify this very important
document MEP is want to make euro pass
more accessible including to people with
disabilities they are asking for
technical adjustments to the platform to
make this possible a new tool has also
been created the e-portfolio the
portfolio is gathering the information
about a single individual engine in one
place there is also another way of
putting it's like electronic briefcase
when you get old ink in one place
recruitment processes will be made
easier thanks to a digital skills
intelligence data system that makes
skills and qualifications more
transparent across the EU the online
platform will also safeguard citizens
personal data a new modernized euro pass
is about facilitating mobility across
Europe for its citizens and making
Europe's job market accessible tool
[Music]